i'm sitting in mercedes-benz's new
s-class but this is a special vehicle
because it's fitted with a new level 3
autonomous drive system drive pilot and
i'm about to test how that system works
level three means i don't have to watch
the traffic i don't have to grab the
steering wheel i can just let the car
let the machine do the work and it will
drive autonomously
drive pilot is part of mercedes push to
lead in automotive software and it's a
step up from tesla's so-called autopilot
system which is classified as level 2.
mercedes engineer florian kunkel
accompanied me on my drive through
berlin
so now i still have my hands on the
wheel i'm driving um we're about to
put in the level three assistance system
i'll do that now right i'll push this
button here exactly you push one button
or both
and now the system is being activated
and now it's active it tells you to stay
awake and you see for the next
you know one kilometer you can draw the
car with my view and i'm not doing
anything as you see i'm not on the brake
i'm not on the car i'm not on the
accelerator um
the cost is itself i can see
very well the car in front of me in the
car next to me
and we are in a heavy traffic situation
here on berlin's uh city autobahn and
it's very convenient that i don't have
to do anything because it's very
stressful as you can see here
um now
how
does the car
see its surroundings briefly
it sees the surroundings by a couple of
sensors we have a radar sensor we have a
stereo camera and we have a lidar sensor
and integrating these three sensors is
our main main sensor set for the driving
tasks supported by a couple of auxiliary
sensors yeah the software is so far as
green lighted for use on suitable
stretches of germany's audubon highway
at speeds of up to 60 kilometers per
hour that's about 37 miles per hour it's
still somewhat limited though lane
switching isn't allowed and the system
usually won't operate in longer tunnels
but mercedes says the current version of
drive pilot is just the start
when do you think
a system like this could be available
for faster speeds even or for inner city
driving yeah well obviously 60
kilometers on a motorway is the first
step of everything we are continually
evaluating the options to
to to enhance the speed to broaden the
operational design domain to broaden the
area where it works and you will
see in the following time with us within
us
mercedes is working on offering the
system elsewhere in europe and the us
and the german company expects that the
technology will eventually trickle down
to some of its other models as well i
assume you're still refining it and
you're still developing right exactly
we're always developing and defining it
and looking how to extend the scope and
thinking very hard about what the future
of automated driving will be
this is how we move i'm stefan nicola
for more content like this follow us on
your favorite platforms